via un tournoi de danse organisée à kiev
le gagnant remportera 30000 euros
sera-t-on une opération études en serait
encore mieux qu'avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le père tendue elle quittera définitif
pour le concours 13 ne vient pas est ce
qu'ils se seraient des filets non parce
que je vais gagner de toute façon
topanou salut toi tu joues mais il y à
une plainte contre lui
sa place est derrière les barreaux
dis moi qu'est ce que tu aurais à
m'offrir toit des rollers c'est quoi
l'amour pour toi juste bon pour les
contes de fées elle rêve d'un prince où
est elle laissons le danser
[Musique]
si vous êtes là vous avez été
sélectionné
[Musique]
quand tout sera fini où la tuerie
je fais ça parce que je t'aime
il va danser